vi ricordate chi sono se voi foste
malati di alzheimer no non vi
ricorderete come mi chiamo anche pochi
secondi sarebbero bastati per cancellare
quello che avete appena sentito se voi
foste malati di alzheimer non vi
mancherebbe soltanto il ricordo del mio
nome mi mancherebbe ricordo di quello
che avete mangiato oggi a mezzogiorno di
quello che avete fatto stamattina delle
persone che avete incontrato ieri di
quello che avete studiato un mese fa del
viaggio che avete fatto l'anno scorso
della casa dove avete sempre abitato e
della strada per raggiungerla del lavoro
che sapevate fare del volto della
persona che amava ta e dei figli che
avete avuto io ho dovuto diventare la
memoria di mia madre che prima di
smettere di parlare mi chiamava mamma e
vedete una cosa e amare la propria madre
o il padre e la moglie o nonno e amarla
teneramente tanto da non volerlo
abbandonare in altre mani ma un'altra
cosa e doverla curare e accudire h24
quando non dorme e aggressiva vuole fare
le stesse cose di prima ma non è più
capace non si vuole lavare non sa più
mangiare e in continente vuole uscire
cammina ininterrottamente insulta oppure
piange e non sai perché
urla e non sai perché vuole la madre
morta 50 anni prima e non sai cosa dirle
e ti chiede sempre le stesse cose mille
volte al giorno oppure non parla più non
ti riconosce ha paura di te e tu non sai
capire se sta male o se ha dolore e le
storie di demenza si assomigliano tutte
la demenza sovverte rivoluziona le
esistenze che colpisce di malati e
familiari
siamo fatti di memoria siamo quello che
siamo
per la nostra storia e il tempo che
abbiamo vissuto e cia plasmati e se il
filo della memoria della nostra vita si
rompe e ne rimangono dei pezzi o si
riannodano in maniera casuale
cosa ne è della nostra identità e se le
relazioni d'amore qualsiasi tipo d'amore
sono fatte di memorie condivise
che ne è della relazione se quelle
memorie vengono cancellate se mi viene
tolta la memoria del tempo in cui sono
diventata madre come è successo a mia
madre che ne sarà dell'amore che provo
per mio figlio e sapesse quanti figli ho
incontrato disperati perché la madre non
li riconosce più
quanti mariti o mogli increduli o feriti
a raccontare storie d'amore tenerissime
non più ricordate scomparse dai ricordi
del coniuge ma parlo di emozioni mentre
la demenza è una malattia
certo una malattia bastarda che ruba la
vita nella quale la perdita di memoria è
la caratteristica principale
ma è una malattia con un esordio lento e
subdolo con manifestazioni cliniche
diverse che variano da persona a persona
e spesso a periodi di parziale
equilibrio succedono riacutizzazioni
improvvise catastrofiche che
destabilizzano sempre più il malato e
chi per 24 ore al giorno deve prendersi
cura di lui diventa irraggiungibile per
le vittime dell'alzheimer quello stato
di completo benessere fisico psichico e
sociale che lo ms nel 1948 ha definito
come è stato di salute ebbene sì io ne
faccio una questione di diritti
basta un ritardo nella diagnosi una
mancata terapia un'indennità di
accompagnamento negata una reazione
catastrofica non controllata
la non disponibilità del curante esperto
un ricovero ritardato oppure inadeguato
per destabilizzare irreversibilmente il
fragile equilibrio di una famiglia
colpita dalla demenza e il malato come
qualsiasi individuo ha necessità per il
suo benessere di veder rispettata la
propria volontà mantenute le proprie
scelte i propri convincimenti per poter
vivere anche malato secondo i propri
valori ha diritto di raggiungere la
certezza di non tramutare in tragedia la
vita delle persone amate e la speranza
che la propria malattia non pesi troppo
sulle loro esistenze ha diritto a non
essere stigmatizzato deriso abbandonato
mai curato maltrattato ma oggi come 31
anni fa quando ho fondato anima il peso
dell'assistenza e mettiamo ben in chiaro
la tutela dei diritti ricade
sostanzialmente sulle spalle dei
familiari e gli eau volentieri
continua a ricoprire il ruolo di spina
nel fianco del welfare italiana non è
normale che in 30 anni il nostro sistema
di protezione sociale che il nostro
sistema sanitario non abbiano ancora
trovato il modo di farsi carico di 700
mila malati ogni cosa oggi a
disposizione dei malati di alzheimer e
di demenza in genere è stata conquistata
con una battaglia di i'm petizioni
emendamenti sciopero della fame ricorsi
comunicargli da battaglia per i centri
di diagnosi farmaci per la qualità
dell'assistenza per promuovere i piani
nonostante ciò la presa in carico del
paziente e squisito appannaggio della
famiglia del caregiver che è diventato
tale per caso all'età o con le
esperienze più diverse senza
preparazione senza strumenti né
conoscenze
tutto inizia da una scelta consapevole o
no obbligata o libera
a cui si è spinti forse da
condizionamenti affettivi ambientali
forse da ricatti o imperativi della
morale personale altre scelte non
sembrano possibili e a volte la stessa
posizione anagrafica non consente altre
ipotesi
si tratta in ogni caso di un atto
privato di assunzione di responsabilità
che purtroppo viene fatto in totale
solitudine il caregiver si percepisce
come l'unico garante del benessere del
malato come una sorta di baluardo contro
la morte ed è schiacciato dal peso del
lavoro della fatica della parente
inutilità di quello che si può fare
della responsabilità di vita e di morte
che si impadronisce di lui è così
l'amore l'amore per i coniugi per i
genitori o per un parente diventa una
condanna una condanna a vita troppo
spesso sento dire proprio questo dai
caregiver dei malati sono gli arresti
domiciliari sono in galera questa non è
vita
non credevo di finire così speriamo di
morire presto nella maggior parte dei
casi sono donne quelle che curano in
molti casi sono quarantenni e
cinquantenni che lascia nel mondo del
lavoro per non tornarci mai più figli
onore che decidono di dedicarsi alla
cura del loro caro malato perché
l'economia familiare già vacillante non
può sostenere costi rilevanti come
quelli di una badante regolare o di una
casa di riposo in tanti altri casi la
donna più anziana 60 70 anche 80 anni la
moglie la sorella la cognata alla quale
sembra naturale prendersi cura del suo
caro malato ma poi quando il peso della
cura diventa insostenibile l'aiuto
diventa indispensabile scopre che le
pensioni tutte insieme non possono
sopportare il costo di una badante o di
una retta di ricovero nonostante il
rapporto ms 2012 raccomandi di agire
subito per considerare le
se una priorità sanitaria e sociale e
nazionale in tutti i paesi e per
investire nei sistemi sanitari e sociali
per migliorare l'assistenza e servizi
per i pazienti e ai loro familiari
nonostante al g8 di londra nel dicembre
2013 si sia ribadito che la demenza di
alzheimer rappresenta una priorità
nell'agenda globale per i prossimi anni
e necessita di politiche a sostegno
dell'innovazione dell'assistenza dei
pazienti affetti da demenza nonostante
la recente joint action europea alcol
raccomandi a tutti gli stati membri di
sviluppare una strategia olistica
tridimensionale indirizzata allo
sviluppo di strutture e organizzazioni
assistenziali in italia non ci sono
finanziamenti per il piano nazionale per
le demenze persino la corea dal 2008 ha
un piano finanziato e la francia nel
2009 ha investito 1,6 miliardi di euro
nel piano demenze l'italia invece nel
2016 è ancora ferma alle enunciazioni di
principio che non bastano certo se si
vuole disegnare una politica sanitaria
anzi un welfare degno di una
costituzione che esclude differenze tra
i cittadini e sancisce il diritto alla
cura per tutti deve cessare questa
italia due forse tre velocità nella
quale un cittadino con demenza di matera
ha meno diritti del cittadino con
demenza di milano che a sua volta a meno
diritti del cittadino con demenza che
abita a bologna che a sua volta a meno
diritti di un suo concittadino malato
oncologico deve cessare la delega
strumentale al volontariato
dell'accompagnamento del sostegno alle
famiglie
facciamo comodo perché non costiamo ma
quando si tratta di pianificare o
decidere
allora improvvisamente la nostra
competenza non serve più deve cessare
l'indifferenza che circonda la demenza
quell'indifferenza che ha indotto 30
anni i governi a rispondere sempre non
ci sono soldi
come se i numeri della demenza non
facessero gridare all'emergenza come se
il problema nel suo complesso non
rappresentasse una gravissima ipoteca
una bomba innescata in attesa di co
scoppiare sul futuro dei nostri figli
quando noi saremmo malati per ora finché
la memoria tiene cerchiamo di non
dimenticare mai che la civiltà di un
popolo si misura anche dalle condizioni
di vita dei suoi vecchi non vorrei dover
dar ragione a quel vecchio professore
che pochi mesi fa mi ha detto vede
signora non si deve aspettare grandi
cambiamenti perché questi pazienti sono
considerati dalle nostre istituzioni
soltanto dei vuoti a perdere
no io questo non posso a cercarlo e voi
[Applauso]